hi everyone it's Millie Bobby Brown and
this is my wired autocomplete interview
I have done this before and I really
enjoyed it so I'm really excited
I feel lonely but it's quite fitting
because the film is all about Enola
being alone so here we go bring it in
how Millie Bobby Brown
became an actor I became an actor at the
right age of eight I've always loved
kind of performing in whatever capacity
that was dancing singing the whole lot
and I became an actor but I just
being bored on a Saturday really
there's not much else to it how does
Millie boy Brown hide her accent I don't
I will like switch in between sometimes
I'll just go straight into my American
accent which is a lot harder and I could
maybe finish the autocomplete interview
like this okay so how did Millie Bobby
Brown and Jake Bon Jovi well I don't
know
how did Millie Bobby Brown and Jake Bon
Jovi that's my question oh it's meat oh
oh God that's embarrassing um how do we
meet we met on
Instagram
the the old Instagram and uh we were
friends for a bit and then um
what can I say how to be Millie Bobby
Brown well you wake up every day grab
yourself a coffee you um you go to work
for at least 14 hours a day and uh you
do wireless interviews and that's that's
how you that's how you are me okay so
good luck with that next I'm so excited
about this which one's this oh no oh no
oh no
it's not stuck anymore does Millie Bobby
Brown okay know how to drive I do I do I
got my driver's license when I was 15
and a half no actually sorry I got my
palm and I was switching it up and then
I got my driver's license when I was
16. so yeah it's been I'm a really good
driver I actually only got pulled over
twice before and I uh just showed him
the old
and he let me go so I don't recommend
that though I was terrified actually the
whole time and I didn't get a ticket
which was great does Millie way around
actually have the 11 tattoo speaking of
that I do indeed I have a seven tattoos
I have one on my back of flowers one on
my
right here I don't know what my ribs a
one here and another one on my foot does
midi boy Brown play video games I play
Sims 4 and I love it I like live mode
and I also like building homes in it I
also have a vet in it so I'm just
leaving vicariously through my Sims
character I also like to play fortnite
from time to time but I
mostly Bush Camp until the very end of
the game until there's like five people
left and then I and then I hand the
controller over to an experienced
fortnite player to let them finish the
game so it's been it's been hard but I
don't really like video games I'm not
very good at them does really Brown no
martial arts
I wish I could say I do I think I got
like two black stripes on a white belt
that's not nothing yeah it's not nothing
exactly pull that face at me next flower
is Millie Bobby Brown a producer of
Enola homes I am I am the producer of
another homes um this is your first turn
as a producer this will be my third time
producing the first film was yes my
first time I've producer but now I've
it's been a minute but I'm only 18 so
it's not been a minute really it's maybe
around cousins with Noah indeed I am no
I'm not although I wish I was no Noah
and I are best friends
but I wish we were oh no schnapp sorry
for guys last name it
um
the whole
Walk of Fame no I'm not and I think
like you need to have a certain
set of skills would you want one um sure
thing I mean I got one from Amazon
I put it in my office but uh other than
that sure I'd be grateful for anything
at this point
alrighty next up does Millie Bobby Brown
like waffles
no I don't people think I do but
actually in stranger things I had a
little spit bucket next to me and I'd
spit into it because I couldn't swallow
the waffles because I'd gag can Millie
Bobby Brown Cry On Cue
I can
but I won't for this was Billy boy Brown
on Hell's Kitchen oh God I was actually
when I was nine we can slowly move past
that don't play a video of it it's
embarrassing he also sent all the chefs
out of the kitchen because they I think
they undercooked something and so we
didn't get dessert also best moment of
my life was Millie Brown named after the
singer Bobby Brown no I wasn't I was
named after myself Millie first name
Bobby coming from my father his name's
Bobby and my last name um goes way back
what are Millie Bobby Brown's Hobbies I
rescue animals
that's my hobby
um other than that
I like to bake I don't really like
cooking but if I have to I will yeah
that's it I went through like an
embroidering period of my life but then
got really bored so it's like phases
what was Millie Bobby Brown's favorite
song All Too Well the 10 minute version
Taylor Swift
what was Millie way around first movie
that I was in or what I watched fast
maybe I watched E.T first movie I was in
Godzilla king of the monsters
what is Millie Bobby Brown's car
hmm
what Millie Bobby Brown favorite food
carrots I'm a rabbit I love carrots and
when I feel like I'm about to faint I
need a cube of cheese and if you are
Devil Wears Prada fan you'd know what
I'm saying here
actual robot carrots uh raw
um I I am not a fan of also as soon as
you boil them all the goodness and
antioxidants and all that thing come out
of them so raw merely Bobby Brown just
plain old Jimmy Fallon wrap that would
be something I did that one time on
Jimmy Fallon I wrapped
multiple things I wrapped a recap of
season one and I also wrapped Monster by
Nicki Minaj is that going to be like a
new career sort of twist no
no I'm gonna just leave it up to Nicki
Minaj to to do that I will definitely
stick to my my day job rescuing animals
Millie Bobby Brown Emmy oh well this is
I don't really know much about what this
really means but I I definitely was
nominated twice at the ripe age of
12 and 14 I think alrighty
that gives me anxiety Millie Bobby Brown
purple pants Fallon it might have been
family oh oh oh
see I didn't know that but this is
exciting that people think you know
people just write my name with it with a
purple pants next to it I mean this is
very exciting I I didn't know there was
much hype about the things that I wear
but thank you those purple pants were a
little bit itchy they were great they
look great and um
they were tight Malibu Brown Comic-Con
oh gosh oh no
ah
I have been to over 40 Comic Cons big
Comic-Con girl I love visiting a
Comic-Con I love going there and I also
love being someone there like I love
meeting fans that I think it's a very
good and safe environment to meet fans
all right
first surprise Millie Bobby Brown purple
pants very big surprise for me didn't
think anybody really cared that is my
wired auto complete interview I hope you
enjoyed will you be back for part three
I absolutely will be back for part three